[Music]
Aaron Rodgers you're the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen you've been
carrying the scene for a decade one more
time for the greatest quarterback we've
ever seen
[Music]
welcome to Sims and left go this is Sims
I am left gonna say anything hey what's
up everybody I'm since that was awesome
packed show today Sims Sean McVeigh
remembering plays we got Martellus
Bennett in studio the guy's hilarious
awesome he's the man and we have an
incredible story of DeAngelo Hall with
Paris Hilton and that guy from Baywatch
ha ha David Hasselhoff is his name don't
worry I'll help ya keep going there limp
along he's why people think we're
scripted but we were we really do love
Aaron Rodgers with all of our heart yes
can you explain to people how hard it is
to do what he did on Sunday with that
leg I mean it's something I look at and
go left code there's only a few
quarterbacks in the history of the sport
that I think it could play with that
that was phenomenal let alone to be able
to get the amount of power and velocity
on the ball that's needed like the
geronimo geronimo Alice's bottom two
yards in the air with a bum leg on one
leg yes we just saw Rodgers get hurt
last year is it worth the risk why is he
not thinking about being injured how
does he handle that I think this is one
of the thing that goes untalked about in
the sport you know why he can go I'm
playing no matter what cuz he just got
long-term security then why doesn't
already talk about that cuz he just got
the college he got a huge contract so
now he's goes okay the team's back to me
and I'm gonna do everything to prove
them right by giving me all this money
and I know they gave me all this money
to be the leader of the team and I'm
gonna go out there and show everybody
even though I'm hurt I can make it
happen I'm so happy they pay Oh Aaron
Rodgers you're the greatest quarterback
we've ever seen it Sims and it's time
for whoa big tank
the Internet's funny man something
happens at a football game they jump all
over it like our boy Sam Donald's right
everybody's expert sever their act so
everybody has a slant we're here to
straighten it out
and I saw a lot of attack on Big Ben on
Sunday and I get it had a lot of pics
here are some of the take Sims I want to
straighten them out first one as a
Steelers fan I'm officially over the big
Ben Roethlisberger era shake my head it
can take this one big Ben Roethlisberger
is that you
a floating dumpster river and then we
even had like a more official article
Ben Roethlisberger's five turnovers cost
the Steelers big time and tie with brown
oh okay um I feel like 9q Captain
Obvious
well where do you stand on the big
Benesch trash yeah I know he's trash I
mean he only was fifth in touchdowns
last year in the NFL he only threw for
469 yards and five touchdowns he gets
the best defense in football in the
divisional playoff game and then when we
get to this game yeah one okay he threw
three interceptions only one was his
fault one time there was a
miscommunication with Antonio Brown
another one went off Jesse James head
are we gonna blame Ben Roethlisberger
for fumbling when the center snapped the
ball on the ground and then no one
blocked Myles Garrity's he got
blindsided I didn't know Ben was
supposed to snap the ball block the left
end and throw the football they should
be paying him more and missed the field
goal and over 200 and Misty and me
wasn't it James Connor who fumbled and
they returned the ball back to the
one-yard line
I'm sick of unqualified people making
qualifying statements I'm sick of it Wow
yeah so Big Ben he's still really
awesome he's one of the best deep ball
throwers in the football and let's not
forget it was a monsoon in Cleveland oh
yeah yeah oh I forgot about that and
Cleveland's defense is gonna be one of
the best of football okay next subject
let's go I'm actually super excited that
you're mad but we don't like to take our
anger out on the players it's really the
coach's fault in Week one here's a
little segment that we like to call
ghetto where are we starting oh we're
starting with the Falcons red zone
offense oh we're gonna get the ball more
to Julio Jones this year we're gonna be
more creative in the red zone
oh here's the plan for week 1 against
Eagles straight line straight line
straight line what the hell were you
doing all offseason God oh hello Cowboys
offense I haven't seen you this
here what the hell did you do this
offseason did we come up with a game
plan or anything schematically creative
to help out the pass game or dak
Prescott probably not
gosh oh and the Saints defense I don't
know what you've been doing in the off
season for the last five years
you can't win a week one game and
everybody was open against its magic I
mean it was the greatest show I've ever
seen and it was the Bucks and Ryan
Fitzpatrick
oh hello Seattle we're gonna protect
Russell Wilson and help him out more
this year it's going we're going to
Denver and oh okay they have von Miller
we'll just leave a one-on-one against
our crappy right tackles all game and
let Russell figure it out and just run
away Gotham man that feel good man I
feel a lot better
whoo this is like therapy I had to get
that off my chest if there's one coach
though that definitely is prepared it's
Sean McQuade they won their first game
by 20 and their team did even play all
preseason he's so prepared he never
forgets a thing we saw you on television
and you remembered a ton of place okay
what do you think of Sean's bring what
it's out of this world is better than
mine I can tell you that week twelve
Saints at Rams 429 in the second quarter
second and seven on the Saints seven
what happens Oh Josh Reynolds touchdown
off schedule flavors a three-man rush
you're absolutely are you kidding me
you're unbelievable now we are gonna go
to this is Sean macfay time in
Washington Oh
bringing it back to 2015 week seven
bucks at skins second and seven on the
Tampa Bay 24 58 seconds left in the
fourth quarter
Jameson Crowder wheel we're out down the
right sideline Seamus it Crowder we were
out down the right sideline South the
first down and then out of that Drive
end Jordan Reed touchdown and a four by
one individual ISO slant and what meme
was that game you like that brain on
shore amazing all right 2005 NFC
wild-card game
Washington and Tampa Bay 947 left
third and two on the Washington to yard
line oh well this is my play this is
their cheating to make it equal they're
cheeky what's the play hi bootleg out to
the left and dobin for a touchdown one
of my only member I only rushing with
the Bucks my first year in coaching yeah
really
remember it's um breakfast together what
did we get breakfast when I worked this
was before I coached for the Bucs yeah
it was when I was working training camp
the year after they had won the Super
Bowl
well I was working everybody remembers
todd gurley screen for a touchdown
against the Cowboys what happened the
play before the big touchdown Green and
Malcom Brown and that is why he's Sean
McMann there's only like a few people I
think in the world that can keep up with
us and I think are funny and I think
Martellus Bennett is one of those guys
well thank you I think that's a
compliment
yeah it was a weird compliment your
brother too he could be with us too oh
yeah that would've been good yeah you're
two of our favorites
you know the grape doesn't fall far from
the vine that's what they say yeah I
like such a quarterback I get to sit
next to him Joe right also I think this
is the Eagles fans now well I don't know
he's officially an eagle I am I Eagles
fan
I hear you jump on the bandwagon I do
not know I'm a Michael Bennett fan yes
yes he plays for the Eagles so I'm
rooting for him to do well so I'll root
for them to do well yes okay fly Eagle
fly is the worst song ever it takes to
the national anthem right
the EAG elias at the end though come on
no I don't like any of it but I mean if
I played for them I would love it
perfect but you're saying it's like
saying I like country music
I would love country music but I don't
like country music what was it like
Sunday being a fan that's like your
first I didn't watch much football
Sunday what did i do on Sunday Sunday
oh I was at Harvard our first Sunday was
not the same that's why he's a lot
cooler than me I mean my first Sunday
without football I was a wreck I was
crying
really I was the like the exact opposite
I was watching every game and like I
can't believe this guy's playing and I'm
not so good I was wondering this oh yeah
is it different we retired when you want
to retire and when the league pushes you
I think so and they push me out see I
retired when I wanted right Oh again so
I'm happy with what I did you know a lot
of guys I think they're I want to say
bitter nicer but they're bitter about
someone else being in if like they still
could do it again so go play then you go
try out for the Canada team that never
we - not happening no NFL or nothing you
were talking earlier about retiring when
you want and be enforced town I feel
like I'm looking at des and I'm seeing
the tweets and I can see the frustration
and you've been in that organization
what the hell's happening with des right
now these teams could build perceptions
about players right and if you take a
meeting and you don't kill that
perception in a meeting they start to
believe what again what reality yeah it
becomes your reality so I think what des
this thing I think that you know trying
to control the situation but the same
time the best thing you could do to
control the situation is just chew mmm
physically you can still play there's
like people saw in Eric Decker and yes
like you know there's receivers getting
signed all the time now the talents
there like air greed like there's
safeties getting something they can't
play better than air agrees just like
but you can't pass up on his guy and
game though how do you see des n didn't
like end game here because I don't want
him to go too long without playin here -
cuz like I like des - I don't think he's
a superstar anymore but I want to see
him on the field and he deserves to be
on the field I look at teams that I
think would be good I think one teammate
to come to mind for me that were being
great for him would
the Chargers I think the personality of
the quarterback is gonna make des a
better player right so playing with a
Tom Brady or playing with a Philip
Rivers who has that fire yes and Komachi
des is firing he believes in that fire
there's gonna be a better situation for
him because he's my heart they both have
that mutual respect for one another
right as far as competitors all these
coaches talk about they want guys who
love football like let's get some
football guys in here and they but when
you have a guy who loved football so
much mmm then they label him as a guy
that's like a diva but he just wants to
win he wants to play and he loves
playing football so if you could get
those three things out of most guys cuz
most guys don't really love it the way
they say they love it they just say that
[ __ ] until they get the check because
most these people aren't who they really
say they are just a facade yes and
Fugazi yeah just they just played a game
very well that was an issue playing a
game I was into playing a game of
football
all right Ellis we appreciate you man
again check out Martellus show mostly
football yahoo and complex and my new
podcast called revenge of the jocks oh
you're the jock yeah I want a little
more flavor than you you're like you
know like you'll have as much cacao
[Laughter]
who's going guys I'm Reggie Bush and
you're watching Sims and let go so if
you know sims enough go you know that
when he's evaluating players you really
care about two body parts the legs and
the ass a lot of people are weirded out
right you believe that if you got those
two things you're gonna be good you got
a chance Lawrence Taylor Reggie White
Barry Sanders you look at their lower
halves it's pretty impressive and then
you can go man Hall of Fame type of
players yes there don't be blinded by
the by so that means nothing right so
take me through five guys at different
positions that you think have a nice set
okay well let's start at the running
back position because this guy here
rookie say Quan Barkley I mean this is
the most unbelievable lower half I've
ever seen on a running back maybe I mean
his nickname is say quad and he's been
there for a few months and Lefko have
you ever seen anybody bounce outside on
Jacksonville Jaguars and run for a 68
yard touchdown
that doesn't happen that's
because he has an unbelievable legs and
ass let's go to defense osa Joey Bosa is
incredible lower half you want to know
why he's one of the best speed pass
rushers in football power pass rushers
he can do it all he's awesome in run
blocking so yes another guy from the
stem it's all stems from down there
let's go to a rookie rookie to run pace
so impressive the first time I people
know this guy the romm pain is going to
be one of the best interior defensive
linemen in this sport and you could see
right there I mean it looks like he's
got a turkey in there I don't know what
that is but all I know is I turned on
the first preseason game when he was
playing the Jets and things like that I
said who is this guy with this legs and
butt and who was creating havoc all over
the building yeah oh it's 95 Derron
Payne watch out for him look out for him
that's a guy in a similar position
that's been doing it for a while this is
not just legs and asses legs and Hiatt
oh this is it it's a little different
it's nuanced here yes his high ass is
what's very impressive to me look how
comfortable he is in that position and
he has a freaky lower half and then the
last guy I didn't expect a quarterback
to be on this list really read if you
always wonder why is Russell Wilson
breaking tackles right all because of
his legs and running around everywhere
we saw him in training camp three years
ago we know he probably has some inner
thigh Chaffins there but it's
unbelievable to see a quarterback with
that type of lower half it's really rare
for that position but he does make the
list he can make some unbelievable plays
with his legs it's about as good as I've
ever seen at the quarterback position so
if you want to steal sims's idea look at
legs and ass one guy that stolen a lot
from you oh my gosh Angelo ho-ho he I
mean every time he was on the field I
felt like I threw an interception to him
yeah I threw a lot of interceptions oh
well you look he's amazing and he's got
an amazing story about a little trip to
Vegas rookie hazing is always legendary
yes I can't imagine what it's like when
you're the eighth pick in the draft they
feel like you got money to burn yeah and
so they tailed me I got to take him to
Vegas rookie hazing I'm like all right
cool I've never been to Vegas and one
night we pick a club you know it's DB
night I'm rookie I got to pay for
everything
yeah and I was kind of looking at the
bottles that we were anticipating or
buying and I'm looking like you know I
was kind of doing that but as the night
wore on man it was it was bigger than
that on one side of our table it's Paris
Hilton and her crew of lovely ladies on
the other side is David Hasselhoff and
his crew of lovely ladies as well he had
on a black kind of shiny shirt
unbuttoned to probably his belly button
you know vintage David Hasselhoff gear
that he probably was still wearing right
I had never met another celebrity
besides other athletes I was without a
doubt shocked and like I said man
Hasselhoff had his his crew might have
been better than Paris his crew our
table looking like we probably ain't
even supposed to be in there we're
leavin had no girls over there would I
say we're all just kind of partying at
their tables initially they had joked
about me having to pay for all the tasks
the three those tables because we were
at all the tables yeah we can't let them
go we drunk all day look I'm like well
somebody got the paper that I got our
table our bill ended up being around 15
grand or so and before I could even put
my cart down Paris it took my bill oh my
god and paid my tab damn well she shut
up she had the most money through
working without a doubt but I always
tell people that story and they think
I'm lying but I promise you man it's the
damnedest thing I wish I could meet her
and say thank you
so you're I would say it again I'm a
Paris Hilton so you know she took over
my thousand I kind of got off unscathed
in it's time for somebody in left Co
bleach report gives me money to bet on
Thursday Night Football but I let random
New Yorkers pick the team they win and I
got to pay them and that's why we got to
see my good friend Ali
we are back in the newsstand and that
means that the Eagles have covered the
spread and my main man ally has won
himself some money
yeah congratulations here is 113 dollars
yes and 60
I dropped a dime don't worry about five
cents I've done the math that is 90
packs of starbursts
don't think you're gonna use your money
there now you what are you take the lady
out for a nice dinner no no no I'm gonna
let it build up over the next couple of
weeks
what next couple of weeks I like what
he's saying all right
this week it is the Ravens who just
steamrolled the bills at the Bengals who
hung on to beat the Colts and the Ravens
are favored by one in Cincinnati take me
through your mindset I don't know I like
the last couple of matchups the Bengals
have beat them what five out of six five
the last six times instance now in
Cincinnati no stuff primetime yeah I
like the Bengals really going with the
Bengals Wow even after the Ravens looked
amazing and we quite look good but the
bills aren't the bangles I like the
Bengals I love it yes signing with
Marvin Lewis and the Bengals is that the
official bet yes sir two hundred and
fifty dollars on the Bengals if he's
right I'll be back here next week
sounds great see you next week zooms
luff go back to you so my man Ali is
going Bengals I do like a good defense
at home on Thursday night but does he
get the sim stamp of approval the
Bengals have had the Ravens number the
last few years but I'm going with the
Ravens and I think this is a different
Ravens football team this year
a true Super Bowl contender and they're
finally healthy yes they are if they
can't avoid penalties right if there's a
lot of penalties in your game we're
keeping the same hashtag and you're
frustrated with the refs hit them with
the hashtag keep it in your pants we're
talking about flags and the referees
thank you clarification Sims yeah uh Sam
darn 'old I'm so happy for our young man
Sammy the Savior we welcome to New York
is he finally the answer to the Jets
quarterback woes I do think so and throw
a pick six on your first play ever and
then just nervous act like it didn't
even happen and come back and ball after
that that's why they took him number
three way to go Sammy Sammy Sam is a pro
we're gonna eventually become pros for
since he's out homies mom left oh well
holla holla holla
stand right here we'll make it quick
Sean but you're staying here yeah face
the camera a little bit more okay hello
and welcome
I am split right now no this one's done
he knows where the cameras are but their
football brainiacs hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the bee
our YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot other videos check them out
and then what time does our show come
out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or be
square
he ruined it it was really close